[Aplausos]
[Música]
la guerra de ucrania ha puesto patas
arriba la agenda política mundial de
repente los ojos de todo el mundo se han
vuelto a desplazar hacia europa y rusia
y ucrania y el petróleo y el gas parecen
copar toda la actualidad sin embargo
habéis escuchado alguna vez esa
expresión que dice que lo urgente no te
impida ocuparte de lo importante pues
exactamente en esas están los eeuu y
particularmente la administración de joe
biden queridos amigos amigas la casa
blanca tiene muy pero que muy claro que
a largo plazo la prioridad número uno
sigue siendo asia
[Música]
i
así que lejos de mirar hacia otro lado
lo que quieren en washington es
precisamente pisar el acelerador
aprovechar la inquietud el miedo que ha
generado la invasión rusa y que ahora de
repente eeuu se ha convertido de nuevo
en el socio predilecto en el amigo que
todos quieren tener de esta forma a
finales de mayo del 2022 en plena guerra
de ucrania y mientras el pentágono
seguía enviando más y más armas al
frente europeo el presidente
norteamericano joe biden hizo una
importante visita a corea del sur y
japón dos estrechos aliados de eeuu que
últimamente están como locos por
reforzar sus lazos con la potencia
norteamericana a todos los niveles una
visita que por cierto fue celebrada con
fuegos artificiales y un show aéreo
conjunto por parte de los molestos
vecinos de siempre aviones rusos y
chinos patrullan los cielos de asse
oriental con la visita de biden horas
después de que bailen deje así a corea
del norte lanza un supuesto icbm y otros
dos misiles
el caso es que tal y como ya os hemos
contado por aquí en alguna que otra
ocasión eeuu lleva años impulsando una y
alianzas a lo largo y ancho de toda la
región de asia-pacífico y si durante los
últimos años la política norteamericana
se limitó prácticamente a estrechar los
lazos militares ahora la administración
vaivén quiere hacer lo propio en el
campo político y económico
[Música]
sí como vicepresidente by bien formó
parte de la administración que lideró el
pp el acuerdo de comercio transpacífico
que luego fue abandonado por donald
trump en uno de los grandes errores de
política exterior norteamericana ahora
la casa blanca estudia cómo retomar esa
línea de trabajo todo con una triple
meta tres objetivos que eeuu considera
indispensables para seguir siendo la
gran potencia de asia-pacífico el
primero de ellos del que ya os hemos
hablado largo y tendido en pasados
vídeos basa por frenar la expansión de
la influencia china y demostrar que
estados unidos sigue siendo el actor
imprescindible incluso aunque ello
suponga adoptar una línea mucho más dura
activa y beligerante sobre taiwán maiden
promete defenderte y wang en un aparente
cambio de política de eeuu y aquí tenéis
una cosa muy presente por mucho que
luego la casa blanca y la secretaria de
estado suelen matizar las palabras del
presidente para dejar claro que eeuu no
ha cambiado de postura sobre su política
de la ambigüedad estratégica que
consiste básicamente no dejar claro
cuándo y cómo se defendería en el fondo
no importa que bailén repita una y otra
vez que eeuu se intervendría activa y
militarmente para defender a taiwán no
es algo casual sino toda una declaración
de intenciones
luego el segundo gran objetivo es
intentar estimular la relación a tres
con dos de sus más estrechos aliados
corea del sur y japón es decir
washington quiere que estos dos países
unan sus relaciones y dejen de una vez
por todas atrás sus viejos conflictos
diplomáticos para construir un fuerte
frente democrático en la región hablamos
de dos de los países más ricos y
tecnológicamente avanzados de todo el
mundo dos países que juntos tienen un
pib de 7 millones de dólares y un
presupuesto militar que podrían llegar a
alcanzar los 150 mil millones de dólares
por año
en otras palabras hablaríamos de uno de
los tándems más fuertes del mundo y por
último el tercer gran objetivo de
washington es impulsar una red de
alianzas para lograr una mayor
integración militar política y económica
sobre todo económica con los países de
la región pues bien durante su último
viaje vaivén nos dio muchas pistas sobre
cómo será la nueva política exterior del
'tío sam' estos queridos amigos son los
planes que la administración bailén
tiene para que china no deje de ser más
que un actor secundario atentos
estreno
puede resultar sorprendente pero si algo
nos dice la evidencia es que en las
relaciones internacionales influye mucho
muchísimo la relación personal que
tengan entre sí los diferentes líderes
políticos en las relaciones
internacionales toda la política es
personal porque al final todo se basa en
la confianza y la confianza sólo fluyen
las relaciones personales no amistosas y
francas con tu contraparte por las que
no tienes que preguntarte sobre sus
intenciones vicepresidente joe biden en
corea del sur en 2013 y sabéis que la
visita del líder norteamericano a corea
del sur fue todo un éxito de tal forma
que vaivén y el nuevo presidente
surcoreano parecen haber encajado muy
bien pero por supuesto no estamos en una
telenovela así que aquí las historias de
amor nos resultan un poco indiferentes
estamos en visual político y aquí sobre
todo nos importan los hechos pues bien
en el terreno político eeuu anunció en
octubre del 2021 la creación de un nuevo
marco de cooperación en asia pacifico el
conocido como marco económico del indo
pacífico el nuevo ipc y si corea del sur
ha sido invitado a ser uno de sus
miembros fundadores y por supuesto y una
aceptado ahora bien qué es esto y por
qué diantres washington quiere crear un
nuevo foro internacional si eeuu
simplemente podría volver a sumarse al
cpc pp que ahora es liderado
principalmente por japón y que se ha
convertido en el club de moda
pues bien al contrario que el cpp y pf
no es un tratado de libre comercio que
busca eliminar aranceles y barreras
comerciales por ahora su intención pasa
sobre todo por impulsar la integración
económica de los catorce países
fundadores es decir por ejemplo promover
una regulación próxima intercambiar
experiencias e impulsar acuerdos de
cooperación en materias como la
tecnología la economía digital las
energías limpias o la lucha contra la
corrupción y sobre todo y por encima de
todo lo que busca este foro es
fortalecer la cadena de suministro entre
los países miembros para no tener que
depender tanto de china
a ver no nos vamos a engañar hablamos de
un foro cuya misión todavía no parece
muy clara pero que todo apunta que en
washington aspiran a que este foro se
convierta en uno de los ejes centrales
de la política exterior norteamericana y
que funciona así de contrapeso a
cualquier movimiento de integración
liderado por china como es el caso la
conocida como asociación económica
integral regional
incluso se especula que a medio plazo la
idea que maneja el gobierno
norteamericano es que este marco termine
dando lugar a un nuevo acuerdo de libre
comercio y de cooperación económica
mucho más amplio un acuerdo que por
ejemplo permite impulsar iniciativas
sobre cuestiones tan estratégicas como
los microchips cuya carencia está
afectando mucho a la industria
automovilística tecnológica y militar de
todo el mundo incluyendo por supuesto a
la norteamericana de hecho justo después
de la visita de bailén a corea del sur y
después de que este país aceptará
sumarse al ipc se hicieron dos
importantes anuncios fijaos física de
corea del sur anuncia 195 mil millones
de dólares en inversión para chips
baterías y biotecnología hasta 2026
samsung invertirá 355 mil millones de
dólares para consolidar el liderazgo en
los sectores del chip y biotecnología
para cazar es una idea estas dos
inversiones combinadas suponen el
equivalente a todo el pib de países como
noruega o israel es decir de la noche a
la mañana esta industria se ha
convertido en la prioridad nacional de
corea del sur casualidad difícil pero no
nos quedemos aquí
además del ipc byron y yum también han
alcanzado importantes acuerdos militares
como aumentar las fuerzas americanas de
disuasión desplegadas en la zona para
hacer frente a las provocaciones
norcoreanas así como la frecuencia y
cantidad con la que se desplegarán armas
estratégicas si pyongyang se pasa de la
raya asimismo se volverán a realizar
ejercicios militares conjuntos con la
misma regularidad que se llevaban que se
llevaban antes de que el presidente
mundo cancelarse en muchas maniobras
para no enfadar a kim jong-un pero eso
no es todo también se está especulando
con que corea del sur podría poner
unilateralmente punto y final a las
restricciones militares que xi jinping y
muniáin acordaron para poner fin a las
represalias con las que pekín castigó
gera del sur después de que eeuu
desplegará en este país el escudo
anti-misiles está hablamos del conocido
como acuerdo de los tres noes
[Música]
mediante este acuerdo corea del sur se
comprometió primero que no habría más
sistemas antimisiles en el país segundo
que se uno se uniría a ningún sistema
regional antimisiles liderado por eeuu y
tercero que no formaría parte de ninguna
alianza militar que involucrará corea
japón y eeuu al mismo tiempo todo ello a
cambio de que china pusiera fin a las
represalias económicas que por ejemplo
hicieron desplomarse un 64% las ventas
de hyundai en el gigante asiático que
obligaron al grupo lotes a liquidar
todas sus operaciones en china o que
congelaron el tránsito de turistas
chinos hacia seúl
[Música]
pues bien sea como sea ese acuerdo
parece ahora está [ __ ] finiquitado
aunque eso sí habrá que ver cómo lo
gestiona según ahora bien la relación
con según no es ni mucho menos la única
carta que espera poder utilizar vaivén
exactamente lo mismo está haciendo con
japón el país del sol naciente no sólo
se ha comprometido a expandir su
presupuesto militar reforzar su papel
político en la región e incluso intentar
mejorar su relación con seúl también y
por encima de todo está incrementando su
participación con eeuu y los aliados más
estrechos de este último país sin ir más
lejos japón ha firmado importantes
acuerdos militares con australia y reino
unido de esta forma eeuu está creando
una coalición capaz por sí misma de
frenar a china claro que en esta línea
las relaciones bilaterales no son el
único as que washington se guarda bajo
la manga
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
camino a la disuasión
además de impulsar las relaciones
bilaterales la otra gran prioridad de la
administración bailén es consolidar las
alianzas militares que están a medio
construir estamos hablando sobre todo
del cual nos va a dar muchos detalles
sobre esto porque ya le dedicamos
específicamente un vídeo aquí en visual
político pero sí es cierto que tras la
invasión rusa de ucrania eeuu quiere
ahora pisar el acelerador para terminar
de dar forma a una alianza formada por
eeuu japón la india y australia una
alianza que se reunió en tokio justo
después del viaje de vaivén la corea y
que ha traído consigo algunas novedades
por ejemplo los líderes del quad han
acordado poner en marcha una importante
iniciativa marítima asociación del indo
pacífico para la concienciación del
dominio marítimo sus siglas y pm a los
líderes de quad lanzan una importante
iniciativa para mejorar la
monitorización de las actividades
marítimas en el indo pacífico y esto
para qué sirve exactamente
la idea es que esta nueva asociación
permite incrementar el control a tiempo
real de los mares del indo pacífico por
parte de los países miembros y no sólo
hablamos de una función militar de esta
iniciativa también permitirá controlar
la navegación de los llamados buques
oscuros los barcos que navegan con los
sistemas de detección desconectados y
que suelen estar ligados a la pesca
ilegal el contrabando o al comercio de
países sancionados por la comunidad
internacional como por ejemplo ocurre
con corea del norte
[Música]
y aún más los cuatro del quad también
han acordado la creación de la
asociación de ciberseguridad del quad
cual llamó un enfoque colectivo para
mejorar la ciberseguridad los países del
quad pidieron un enfoque colectivo para
mejorar la seguridad cibernética y
dijeron que coordinarán los programas de
desarrollo de capacidades en la región
del indo pacífico bajo la asociación de
ciberseguridad del cual claro que no
todos son buenas noticias la india se ha
negado a condenar tajantemente la
invasión rusa de ucrania porque teme que
el país de vladimir putin cancele las
entregas de equipamiento militar
luego hablaremos de esto por cierto en
un próximo vídeo en australia los
laboristas han llegado al poder y existe
el miedo de que el nuevo gobierno en
camberra quiera enfriar su creciente
hostilidad con china para reconducir las
relaciones comerciales y lograr que
pekín cancele los aranceles con los que
ha querido castigar a la economía
australiana sea como sea si algo está
claro es que en los últimos años se ha
producido un giro de 180 grados la
posición de eeuu en asia pacifico está
empezando a ser la más fuerte en
muchísimo tiempo de la mano de
corea-japón australia y las alianzas que
están forjando como el quad o el marco
económico del indo pacífico la
administración bailén espera consolidar
la posición de eeuu como gran potencia
en asia-pacífico se hace relativamente
poco tiempo todo apuntaba a que china se
llevaría el gato al agua' el giro de
estrategia política de eeuu lo ha
cambiado todo tanto en el teatro europeo
como en el del pacífico' por supuesto la
partida aún no ha terminado y las
preguntas son lograrán los planes de
baile en llegar a buen puerto tendrá
éxito la estrategia de eeuu conseguirá
washington debilitar el poder y la
influencia de rusia y de china al mismo
tiempo déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo te
resultado interesante no olvides darle
al botón de like i suscribirte a visual
político un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]